[Music]
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and when you give it to
someone else you don't have it anymore
it's not about the money it's about
margin it's about options and it's about
freedom
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage
dave ramsey
[Applause]
thank you guys god bless you
thank you you guys are amazing
thank you so much
so the ballroom
this hotel
was a little bit
tired
kind of
a little dingy you know what i'm talking
about say yes
and i'm the third row
from the front
in the ballroom chairs
that are a little bit
tired
and a little bit dingy
four seats
in i still remember exactly where i was
sitting
it's 1983
i'm 23 years old
i got my real estate license
at 18 years old
and i'd been selling real estate
and i was ready to be
a real estate investor
and i was there to learn
how to buy
investment real estate
with nothing down
because that's precisely how much i had
to put down
nothing
1983 queens we are the champion starts
play
rocky music starts playing
the speaker is a little bit late
on purpose
to draw us in
he gets on stage
he was perfectly fit
unlike your speaker tonight
his suit
was very expensive
unlike your speaker tonight
it was custom tailored
just like your speaker tonight
and he started explaining to us how we
could start with nothing
and by the end of the week we could own
real estate with nothing down
and he described four
very persuasive techniques on how we
might go out that very day and start
looking at foreclosures start looking in
the mls real estate multiple listing
service and finding motivated sellers
that would do these special techniques
four of which i found out later were
illegal
to buy a house
with nothing down and begin our real
estate investing career
and if we wanted to come back for the
weekend seminar for a mere 3 500
we could learn the other 42 techniques
and we would be on our way well i got to
tell y'all i've always been good with
math
i've always had a pretty good intellect
i know i've always been really really
ambitious
and that was all very true in 1983.
so much so that i looked at that guy and
i thought you know what i don't need his
weekend seminar i can figure this out i
think i got i think i figured out what
he's doing here
and i immediately went out and within
four weeks bought my first piece of real
estate without his seminar nothing down
several years later i had four million
dollars worth of real estate
that i had put nothing into except banks
money
and it was only owed about 3 million on
it and so i was a millionaire at 26
years old
i had 250 000 income
at 26 years old
and the banks called our notes and my
income at 27 years old was 6 000.
well i spent the entire year
trying to sell it all before they
foreclosed on it as the house of cards
of nothing down get rich real estate
came crashing
around my ears
well dave you just didn't know how to do
it the guy robert allen who wrote the
book nothing down filed chapter 11
people i mean come on
he was the expert
get rich quick has been around a long
long time
the human heart
is perpetually looking for an easy
button
we're always looking for something quick
in the 1600s in holland
tulips
were considered first
a sign of prosperity
later started to be associated with
wealth
and then tulip bulbs as a result
started to be associated with wealth and
started to become
an investment
people started buying tulip bulbs as an
investment because it represented wealth
and the tulip bulb craze
in holland got completely
out of control
as everyone rushed to get theirs and get
in on the action
fomo was officially invented in holland
in the 1600s the fear of missing out
to the point that by the time it peaked
the great tulip bulb mania of the 1600s
a single tulip bulb that year sold for
10 times the average household income
or today around 750 000
of course you know where this is going
eventually people went what we've
invested in tulip bulbs
and it began to unravel
it crashed
and people lost their fortunes as they
couldn't get out
of the tulip bulbs that they had
overpaid for
in an effort to become
rich bankruptcies happened in the 1600s
due to tulip bulbs
now isn't it funny how to us today that
sounds so absurd but to those people it
was so serious can you imagine the
discussion over the dinner table when
one brother-in-law chose to not be
involved in the tulip craze and was
considered absolutely out of his mind
you've had those discussions with your
crazy brother-in-law lately haven't you
you've decided i'm not going to be
investing in that well you must be out
of your mind
and we'll look back on it later and go
looks like a tulip bulb to me
when the new world was discovered
in air quotes
and
jamestown has formed the la puritan's
land on plymouth rock
the 1600s the first 200 years of
america's history americans really
believed
benjamin franklin's poor richard almanac
they really believed the puritan work
ethic and they really believed in
agrarian culture a situation where
agriculture was where you built your
wealth and it was work and work and work
and work to build your prosperity over
time incrementally and that was how
wealth was built in america thomas
jefferson wrote on it it's how wealth
was built in america for the first 200
years
until 1848.
james marshall
is working for his boss
jim sutter
and
he's building a
windmill
on the california river
in california
and he looked down in the
river and he saw something
shiny
and he had discovered gold
we took it to his boss mr sutter and the
two of them said we need to keep this a
secret because they went back up there
and they found more than one piece of
gold
don't tell anybody because if word gets
out
this will go sideways well i don't know
who talked but one of them did
and word got out
and the great california gold rush
was underway
here we go
wagons wide open across the plain as as
fast as the horses would pull them but
looking for
all that glitters easy money i want to
push the easy button
i need to buy a tulip bulb
california
went from 800
a population of 800 people in 1848 to
1851 just three years later over a
hundred thousand people
had rushed
to find their gold
and their easy fortune
and the american dream was
redefined the 200 years previous to that
the american dream was if you work hard
you steadily incrementally do the right
thing you put corn in the ground you're
going to grow corn you steadily
incrementally do the right thing you're
going to build wealth and you'll prosper
with the back off the back of your hard
work your diligence your intelligence
but now
it was up to daring
and luck
and wealth was now going to be easy
easy money
get rich quick
became the new american dream
the gold rush reformed
the philosophy
of how we in america thought about
wealth and where it comes from
consequently
every few decades every few years since
we've seen a steady spin up
of get rich go broke get rich go broke
and the reason the go broke goes with it
is we got rich the wrong way the 1920s
the roaring 20s come on the stock market
gets completely out of control the
robber barons had turned the marketplace
loose and it was wide open
the great gatsby the flappers all of the
things are happening the economy is
booming it's churning like never before
you've never seen anything like it and
then it crashed
men lost their fortunes and jumped
from the windows
in skyscrapers
also in that same environment there was
a guy named charles ponzi
charles ponzi was the inventor of you
got it the ponzi scheme
one of the greatest cons ever pulled off
and a ponzi scheme is really simple you
take money from investors and you give
it to the investors that gave you money
two weeks ago as if they had gotten a
return on their investment
and it's this spin out the shell game
and you keep hiding the p and gathering
money until someday somebody discovers
there's no p
and the thing comes crashing down it's a
literal pyramid scheme
now known as the ponzi scheme charles
ponzi also got into selling swampland in
florida he was the first
this guy was good
he had he was diversified in his efforts
of course he ends up getting busted
going to jail
but he had left his mark
on america the ponzi scheme
named after him
i know his grandmother was proud
swampland sales in florida continued
the gulf american land corporation
opened a subdivision called
the golden gate estates it was a hundred
and seventy thousand three thousand
square miles of swamp land
forty thousand people bought land that
was under water
this is where have you ever heard that
somebody go well that's a dumb idea and
if you believe that i got some swampland
in florida i'll sell you ever heard that
this is where it came from this company
golden gate estates
swampland
in florida
why would we fall for that
in the 20s
another group
bought it from ponzi
they bought by mail and never even went
to florida
is how good the get-rich-quick
con
was
something for nothing the easy button it
glitters it shines
this is going to be easy
in the 1980s the ponzi scheme was
revived again this time it was called
the airplane ride
the airplane pyramid scheme
several people went to jail on that
puppy too worked exactly like the ponzi
scheme only apparently this generation
had never heard of charles ponzi and
they all fell for it again
and then of course we get the internet
oh thank you jesus
i'm so thankful we have the internet
this is a whole new way to get to people
and anything that's on the internet in
late 1990s 1998 1999 if you open up a
company and the last part of the company
was dot com you were about to be rich
weren't you
it was automatic money and these
companies that had never made any
revenue went public collected
millions tens of millions of dollars in
stock
issuing stock on a company legally right
in front of the securities exchange
commission's nose
and had absolutely never made a freaking
dime and the investors knew it and still
bought it because dot com meant money
so compact went away and people lost
money palm pilot went away and people
lost money alta vista which is the
precursor to yahoo which is the
precursor to google which is the
precursor to duck duck right i mean
it went away it disappeared a lot of you
in this room don't even know what alta
vista was it was the original search
engine poof
there wasn't a lot to search in those
days
but we're going to get rich
easy
what do you mean you're not going to
jump in
on the issuing of the stock oh the
company's never made any money
why would i want to buy stock in a
company that's not made money
scott.com in the name oh i'm in
easy button
go rush
quick and easy
get rich quick is not a
new thing the spanish philosopher
famously said those who don't know
history are doomed
to repeat it
there is nothing new
under the sun the bible says
these things have been around forever
i've been doing our radio show now for
almost 30 years i've seen waves of get
rich quick come through at different
times
there's something happens in the culture
that makes us susceptible at different
times in the in the rhythms of life to
get rich quick and get rich quick is on
fire in the last 18 months
we are seeing it like i don't remember
seeing it ever in the 30 years
nothing down real estate it's back with
a rage
i've got young people watching 19 year
olds on youtube going
dave man
real estate man real estate like it's
new
reminds me of that kid sitting in that
ballroom
when i take a call from some of these
guys
really smart i had good strong intellect
i had a lot of ambition
but i was greedy
and if you want something for nothing
let me help you it means you're greedy
and you're about to get it
you're about to get it
something has happened
with the pandemic
and the resulting inflation
that has shaking people up
and is making them ripe for the picking
for get rich quick because get rich
quick is booming there's a bit of an
existential crisis is my hypothesis
apparently we've got an entire
population that suddenly realize they're
going to die
they didn't know this before the
pandemic
but now we've realized we're going to
die
and so we need to get ours and get it
quickly because this ain't gonna be long
this life is just a flicker
you better jump on it baby you better
get it and you better quit it quick and
then you see inflation and this is a
generation that doesn't know jimmy
carter
they don't know about real inflation
and real inflation is different than
what we've got right now but but they
don't know about inflation they're going
oh god stuff's going up in cost if i
don't make a lot of money quickly i'll
not be able to keep up with inflation
have you heard that say yes
see that's an existential crisis that
sets you up
to fall
for a get rich quick scheme
or an actual con
and sometimes the lines between the two
are a bit blurred
a lot of stuff happening out there right
now robin hood app has gone bananas the
whole game stop marching by that
happened just a few months ago people
just went and it was like
there was this you could just hear it
man it's like a beagle chasing a rabbit
all through a reddit thread just
and if you dare question the
intelligence or the wisdom of this
you will be put outside like the
brother-in-law who dared question the
tulip bulb
and you're not allowed oh you're just a
boomer you don't understand oh baby i
understand more than anybody in the room
that's the beauty of being old you've
seen a lot of stupid
and sometimes you've been a lot of
stupid
and you really got a good up close look
at what stupid is and so you can kind of
recognize it when you see it coming
cryptocurrencies gone bananas
it may someday turn out to be a thing
and it it might actually
pave out but the heartbeat and the
spirit by which people are chasing it is
the same
shrill tone you can feel it there's this
rush
quick easy
money
you can still feel it and when i smell
that i can always tell somebody's
getting ready to get hurt
now i'm not saying cryptocurrency is
going to go away i'm not saying it's
horrible i am saying it's not a proven
track record of building wealth
and people have got this
crazed almost cult-like discussion of it
i get more hate mail over cryptocurrency
what
i mean i've done some stuff you should
really hate me for but that
i mean come on
of course gold is back too which i don't
understand at all
but gold is back
yeah and of course nfts oh yeah that's a
good one let's buy a digital copy of
something
and call that value we'll see how that
works out
i remember several years ago i was
traveling a lot
and my wife made sure every time i went
through an airport that i got a beanie
baby the latest release
we have a full collection of beanie
babies we were heavily invested
in beanie babies
yeah and if you got the like the michael
jordan one it was like wow that's a
thousand dollar stuffed animal
i found it the other day one of the
grandkids had let the dog play with it
and a generation later didn't work out
did it boys
we just moved and we were going through
the moving process and
i opened up
my son's stuff from his
10 year old years 20 something
years ago and we found his old pokemon
cards
and they were very
systematically laid out
in this little book he was a bit of a
nerd look at that i love it and
so we let one of the grandkids start
playing with his pokemon cards because
if you didn't know pokemon's back
god help us
and
then one of the aunts or uncles or
something actually pulled those cards
out and looked one of them up and they
went that one's going for three thousand
dollars we shouldn't let the kids play
with it okay
because these things are the vintage
pokemon cards have turned into
a thing
there's nothing new under the sun y'all
at any given moment in time somebody's
looking for an
easy way
to invest an easy way
to get rich if you search building
wealth on the internet
you'll find one of two things you'll
find these get rich quick things under
the heading of building wealth or you'll
find
and that that usually has an
intellectual component to it
and you can see it with your mind and it
also pulls you in on fear fomo
or greed
it's going to be easy
and if you feel your heart rate change
your eyes start to dilate and you get a
little fomo going
that means
stay away
that's your warning
you're getting ready to make a mistake
because you're falling in the noose of
fear or greed something's happening
you're feeling it physiologically in
your body your heart rate's changing a
little sweat in your palms your eyes are
starting to dilate a little sweat on the
upper lip it's like oh i got i got i got
here hey guys okay this is what's
causing people to pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars more than a house
is listed for
while 83 people make an offer on it
and i just want to stand back and go
this is entertaining
and we didn't even have an auctioneer
you got to watch yourself
and think about what is true what's real
how do you
really keep from getting snookered
even by someone who's well intentioned
but just wrong
how do you keep from getting pulled into
get rich quick and instead find the real
ways to build wealth and to implement
them
a friend of mine's mom fell for it the
other day
she's a sweet lady 74 years old
and she was looking for a a mini
golden doodle
and if you didn't know like everything
else there's a shortage on golden
doodles
which means you have to rush to get one
when you find one get in line know
somebody
fomo you feel it again here we go it's
like the golden doodle
tulip bulb
so
the poor lady gets on god help us
facebook
marketplace and finds a golden doodle
that no one else has found who knew
the people
out of convenience for her agreed to
meet her
with the golden doodle puppy
at the walmart parking lot
she gives them
several 100 dollar bills for the golden
doodle puppy
imagine her surprise after she fed it
for six months and realized it was a
great pyrenees
in the country we call that buying a pig
and a poke
if you've never heard that one that's
what that means you didn't get exactly
what you signed up for and that's what
happens in so many of these things i
sign up for an easy way to build wealth
an easy way to get rich
that no one else knows about and i meet
them in the walmart parking lot
and then later i find out it really
wasn't what i thought it was
things didn't turn out
as
advertised
there was a con man that ran a ponzi
scheme in florida in the 60s he ended up
in jail and wrote his book from jail
called con man or saint john frasca and
john said he's a true con man i mean
he's in jail for being a con man
now he thinks he's a saint that's why he
wrote con manor saint but he's confused
he's in jail
so let's just keep this in mind all
right
and john's comment after conning
thousands and thousands of people out of
millions and millions of dollars in a
ponzi scheme said you can con someone of
any level of education or any level of
intellect if you can activate fear or
greed
anyone
can fall for it
three
rows back
four seats in
anyone
can fall for
a great pyrenees switcheroo
if you've got bad information
and the thing driving it in your heart
is not maturity
not wisdom but it's just unbridled
ambition
with a lot of intellect
you're gonna get your head taken off
true wealth building a good investment
plan is always slow and steady
oftentimes it's boring as a matter of
fact i've worked with thousands and
thousands of millionaires over decade
after decade after decade more than
anyone else you know or anyone else
you're listening to in america right now
i've not only studied them i've walked
among them and it is disgustingly
simple
the things that they do
it's so boring
that you think it must be wrong they
don't the really wealthy people even the
people with 20 and 30 and 40 million
dollars they don't have like double
backflip family partnership limited
thingies
i always ask them what's the secret of
the rich he goes i only invest in things
i know about
wow
i only invest in real estate because i
love real estate i only invest in mutual
funds because i've had a really good
long track record with that but i'm
steady and i never let up okay well
so we find that most millionaires are
401ks
paid for houses
sometimes big farms
and the occasional small business
entrepreneur those are the four
categories that makes the most
millionaires anywhere
and you didn't hear
gamestop margins on robin hood
you didn't hear that in there because
it's not in there
now you might make a million dollars
doing that
but i doubt 10 years later you'll have
any of it
because of the way you got there
will be also the way you lose it
this is how this stuff works so we
discovered that
there's a whole bunch of people now with
over 7 000 fam 7 million families going
through financial peace university and
about 10 million people going through
financial peace university in that
process that these people have followed
these baby steps that we teach
and they have predictably with a system
a proven process
incrementally gently over time with some
hard work and sacrifice
no easy about it
but boring
become millionaires
none of them will tell you it was easy
but none of them will tell you they were
geniuses in their finances that they had
some insight that no one else in the
whole world had
oh bull
the baby steps are simple you know them
first baby step one we save a thousand
dollars a little starter emergency fund
you do that really quick about a month
baby step two you pay off all your debt
except your house
quickly using the debt snowball when
you're out of debt you take all the
money that you used to spend on that
which is twelve to fifteen hundred
dollars a month for the average family
right now in non-mortgage payments you
use that to build your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses in baby
step three and then we're ready to start
the wealth building
now everyone knows the ramsey
organization and dave ramsey for the
baby steps one through three for sure
baby step two for sure the debt snowball
for sure it's no debt dave right
but here's what happens we weren't
getting you out of debt just to get you
out of doubt we were getting you out of
that so that
you can invest and become wealthy
and change your family tree so that you
could be outrageously generous you're
living like no one else so that later
you could live and give
like no one else
there's a method to the madness
and baby step four is 15 of your income
going into retirement now let's look at
that and here's how the actual math
works out the average household income
in america today according to the census
bureau is slightly over 65 thousand
dollars if you save 50 percent of 65 000
that'd be 9 750 about 800 bucks a month
going into your 401k let's take joe and
susie and say they're 31 and it takes
them three or four years to get through
the first three baby steps and at 35
years old they start investing
15
of their average
household income that's 800 bucks a
month going into their 401k and let's
pretend that they don't have a match
which is an unrealistic
thing that we're pretending because 82
percent of the companies that have a
401k in america today have a match
but we're going to pretend they managed
to find one of the 18 that didn't okay
and so they worked for this company and
they put 15 of their
thousand nine thousand seven hundred
fifty dollars a year
eight hundred dollars a month in there
from age 35 to age 65 30 working years
with no match
and they never get a
raise now let me help you with this
if you started average
and you work 30 years
without a race
you're a loser
okay
let's just keep that in mind this is the
assumptions we're running the math on
okay no match and loser okay
never get a raise in 30 freaking years
what who are you
oh yeah okay so but this is this a
conservative assumptions would you agree
say yes okay so at 10
this money will turn into 1.8 million
dollars
no match
and no race
15
of the average
household income going in at 11 it'd be
2.2 million dollars at 12 it'd be 2.8
million dollars my personal mutual funds
with my smart investor pro have averaged
over 12 percent through the last
bazillion years that i've been doing it
which is greater than the stock market
is average and i know some of you can't
fathom that but i do it all the time so
shut up
it's really not rocket science but even
if you didn't do that let's just say
it's ten percent
and let's just say no match and let's
just say no race
1.8 million dollars
let's just say i'm half wrong
you're still a millionaire
the math proves
it not only can be done but it should be
done
how do you get out of the sixth grade in
the united states of america and someone
hasn't shown you this
this is ridiculous
america is the land of opportunity and
guess what math is not racist
math is not
math is not sexist
math doesn't care if your parents are
cray-cray math is just math
math doesn't care if your boss is a
[ __ ] math works
guess what there's all kinds of stuff
out there that's bad in america that you
have to overcome to become wealthy it's
not easy out there but math
works
now keep in mind what will likely happen
is
it won't be 30 years
because they will get raises
and it won't be 30 years
because as those raises come up they
keep putting more and more and more
money in
and they're watching their portfolio you
don't have to be a genius you just
actually have to invest
instead of discussing it
that's all i did everybody gets
paralysis of the analysis with these
nuanced little stupid mathematical
questions that keeps them from actually
joining the game
instead they discuss it
why don't you get in the game
and then we'll discuss it
so your income's going to go up during
that time they're probably going to pay
off their house which we didn't even
have a paid off house in those figures
you noticed that
and so what we end up finding is the
typical millionaire as ramsey solutions
we did our study of millionaires the
largest study of millionaires ever done
airtight research 10 000 millionaires
studied in north america when we did
that study we found the typical
millionaire is hitting between 12 and 17
years from the time they start
their version of baby step four or if
they're actually doing our stuff baby
step four by god
right
and so that's what they're doing
because they're getting raises they're
getting their house paid off and they're
just there and and they're going on
vacation and they're buying a couch and
they're upgrading their car all with
cash they don't go back in debt no debt
no debt no debt and they take what was
all that debt money and they're throwing
it in the 401k it's a pretty simple
basic formula and it works all the time
it works all the time
let's take it a little step further
let's say that joe and susie are able to
do this in 15 years and they get their
first million dollars at age 50 remember
they started at 35
and they quit
investing
and they leave that one million dollars
in mutual funds at market rates of
return
now let me teach you a little math trick
that's out there there's a thing called
the rule of 72 so if you divide an
interest rate into the number 72 it
tells you how many years it takes for a
lump sum to double
so if my interest rate was 7.2 percent
then the lump sum would double in 10
years divided into 72. y'all see how
that works so yes
okay now if so if the interest rate or
the rate of return on the investments is
10
your money's going to double about every
seven years if you do a little better
it's going to double quicker but let's
just use seven years they got a million
dollars at age 35
and they don't add anything to it
seven years or at age 50 i'm sorry at
age 50. seven years later at age 57 they
got two million dollars seven years
later at 64. it's four million dollars
seven years later at 71 it's 8 million
dollars
they did all of that in 15 years of
investing
and an average income with no match
and no raises
and it doesn't count their paid off
house
this is a mathematical set of proof
showing you that we should all be doing
this
we should all be achieving
these heights
so how do we do this
because i don't want people to have to
struggle
i want you to find the easiest way
i'm not against an easy button
i just need to find one that works
and that's why i'm not a proponent of
these other things because they i cannot
find that as a high percentage of the
time that when you invest in gamestop
margins with robin hood that i meet you
20 years later and you're a
multi-millionaire
as a matter of fact i find precisely
zero
that are millionaires i cannot find that
people who buy lottery tickets and call
that their investment
end up millionaires if it worked i would
tell you to do it i can't find any data
that says it i'm not against you winning
however you can do it the easiest way
and the fastest way
i want you to get there
i want it to be fast i want it to be as
easy as possible why work harder than
you need to
but i also don't want to fall for
something
based on my need for easy
that causes me to not have a high
probability of success at the end
and so here's what we know
we know
that when you work the baby steps
exactly as we have laid them out
that 100 percent of the time eventually
even with tragedy in your life you're
going to reach a million dollars
now that means that you're not going
back into debt no matter what happens
that means that you're working on a
budget that means you're doing the stuff
we teach and which is hard during
tragedy it's hard during layoffs it's
hard during pandemics it's hard during
uncertain times i'm not saying this is
easy but when you follow that over time
somewhere between 12 and 25 years you're
gonna hit
a serious net worth figure
that's going to happen all the time
so what's the fastest easiest way i know
to be a millionaire
million to five million not a
billionaire won't work for getting a
billion
you have to do something else to do a
billion if you want to be a billion
we're in the wrong room
this stuff you're not going to be a
billion with your 401k okay just let's
settle that all right
can't get there it's impossible
mathematically
a billion is a thousand million
gonna take a little longer or a
different angle right but your first
level of wealth
on your way to whatever
one to five million dollar net worth
the easiest fastest shortest way
is these baby steps and following them
exactly which involves fifteen percent
going into your 401k your kids college
and getting your house paid off the of
the ten thousand millionaires that we
studied almost all of them the the the
case study icon that developed the
persona of the people now there were
exceptions and different kinds of all
kinds but most of them followed this
about two-thirds of their wealth was in
their 401k retirement plans roth iras
and about a third was in their paid off
house so they found a million and a half
dollar net worth with a half million
dollar house and a million dollars in
their retirement and we found that
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times the number of times we met a
millionaire in the study the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america that made their money getting
airline miles on their credit card
precisely zero
didn't happen
didn't happen
so the fastest
right way
is following those baby steps
and so i need
uh something that keeps me doing that
in my case
i i and financial peace university puts
you on the track and shows you how to do
it and walks you through it and keeps
you on the track people that have even
been through financial peace university
while they're working their baby steps
four five six they're often coordinators
just so they keep their nose stuck in it
so that they can just not get away from
the rhythm of the system
and they stick with it
of the people in financial peace
university that have had the highest
probability of not only getting out of
debt but of building wealth
head and shoulders data above any other
data point is their own a budget the way
we teach a zero-based budget and most of
them these days are using the every
dollar app
over and over and over and over and over
again every month every week they're
checking and it's their guideline it's
like it's this north star how are we
guiding the ship
we want to get there we're walking these
steps this shows us how to get there and
it shows us how to stay on track and for
those of us that are married it helps us
communicate with our spouse and do this
stuff
and you need a coach in your corner
all three of these things are now in a
thing we call ramsey plus
and you get a subscription to that and
you can watch the videos be in the class
at a church or go through them online
you get a coach in person online
you can get the every dollar app
and it's an app
that's it that's the only place you can
get it
and you're getting it all through there
and so if you want to do a free trial
for ramsey plus tonight we want to help
you with that i want to give you
the first 1000 of you that go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth right now and take a free trial
to ramsey plus i'm going to give you a
free copy of the brand new book baby
steps millionaire but by this time next
week will be a number one bestseller
so
i could be wrong but i've sold a few
books and i don't think i'm wrong so
guys i'm i'm really
all the bitcoin guys are really mad at
dave
because he's a boomer and doesn't he
doesn't keep up with technology and he's
not in touch with how things really work
and
and there's a lot of horrible things
being written and said about me out
there i'm really not mad at bitcoin or
even the bitcoin guys they're a bit
cultish right now to say the least but
um but i just all i care about is find
something that works
and that is proven
and once you prove to me not for 20
minutes but once you prove to me
over decades that you've created
thousands and thousands of regular
people and help them create wealth and
become millionaires then i'll sign up
but until then i just think you're a
cute child
a little bit impudent
you're a punk
you can try it if you want to try it you
can throw some money in there you can go
to vegas and throw some money on the
roulette wheel if you want i'm gonna be
mad at you for that i have family
members rachel that does that kind of
stuff
and so
she might have been known to lose some
money at the crafts table it's just a
rumor but
she thinks that's entertaining i don't
think it's entertaining but it's okay if
she wants to she can afford the little
bit of money that you can do that if you
want to play with something small it's
okay do that but i want you guys to win
in the book baby steps millionaires we
outline and we cover several
real baby-step millionaires people that
have really really done it and several
of the people that are actually featured
in the book made it with us tonight and
are sitting right down here you guys
wave everybody
one of the folks sitting down here is my
friend webster webster would you stand
up and wave
so
webster and i've known each other a long
long time he goes back a long way with
ramsey and he's been following this
stuff and stumbling his way through it
and at 64 years old he has a pretty
serious net worth and has done a great
great job and
you know we his story is just so
interesting he's a high school graduate
has a learning disability
went and got 180 different
certifications in technology
went from making 400 a week to 180 000 a
year
over the years overcame overcame
overcame and overcame
started with nothing
and followed the stuff we taught
not perfectly because no one can even
the guy that wrote it can't
but his story is absolutely riveting
so brother we love you thank you for
being with us
so he actually came on the show
when we were doing one of the
millionaire theme hours on the show and
told his story so i want you guys to
watch your story right briefly give
webster a look
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
this is the ramsay show we're talking to
real millionaires webster's with us in
the lobby on the debt free stage to do
is to tell us about being an everyday
millionaire so what's your net worth
webster 1.4 million good for you and
give me a little breakdown on that
retirement real estate so forth uh 250
000
is the house
uh 1 million in retirement
and then 200 000 in
cash and a taxable investment account
good for you well done how old are you
64. what was your what's your range of
income in your working life your best
year working your worst year working
well
worst year was when i first started in
it in uh
1977 making a whopping 400 a month okay
4 800
a year yeah yeah all right up to a high
of 180 180. good for you way to go
and uh what was your gpa in college uh i
have no degree no degree zero degree so
high school education
yes okay good for you i
listened to you i've been listening to
you since um
november 1999 and so over the years
listen to you listen to others
especially when entre leadership started
yeah invest in yourself yeah invest in
your skills invest in your knowledge
so when we started our
so our we just had our 20-year dave
ramsey anniversary on march 25th wow
so when we started i was making 36 000 a
year
okay and then over the four and a half
years that we paid off 197 thousand
dollars
uh our average income was 48 000. my
advice to my 25 year old self would have
been to have listened to a very wise
woman that i knew at the time mrs
campbell
she was day before day was dave
and her advice was
always pay cash
never have debt
always save
and always invest for your future
and always give
yes yeah and i wish my pig-headed
stubborn obnoxious arrogant 20-something
self would have listened to her yeah
yeah this would be four million
[Laughter]
but you did okay webster you still got a
million four i'm so proud of you
congratulations sir you're living the
american dream thank you for taking time
[Applause]
well i brought the gang out with me
rachel cruz
rachel cruz a three-time best-selling
author the latest one was new york times
know yourself know your money and george
camel newly minted ramsey personality
and uh big time on the show these days a
big favorite among our youtube audience
in particular and uh so i brought them
out to have a little discussion and talk
about this stuff that
we were just talking about yeah it was
great well good job dave i just got to
say it wasn't dave great you did good
we'll give you a man
you think i got a future he's got a
ticket i don't know i was like this guy
could sell me a beanie baby right now i
buy it
i wanted those two you still got those
pokemon cards because they i heard
they're worth a lot right now i i think
they were a prop they may be gone i
don't know we talked about sage about
grabbing them off the prop table and
selling them and going on vacation
because i think they are worth something
else well you could use them at the
craps table yeah i know that's right
that's right
well i always think this discussion is
always interesting
when it comes to building wealth because
as you just talked about at the at this
at the beginning of this event there's
so many ways there's so many angles
everyone has their opinion
and looking to see okay what are the
things no matter what that you have to
be doing so no matter what baby step
you're on whether you're starting for
the first time tonight maybe or maybe
you've been doing this for for 30 years
but for me the thing i always go back to
one of the foundational principles
that is key just to remind you all again
is the budget so when we look at being
intentional with our money it takes
intentionality to build wealth
and it takes intentionality just day to
day
with your money and i've had so many
conversations with
friends and even family and
looking at the subject of budgeting
because it is
i keep going back to it in these
conversations telling people and
encouraging people this is the thing you
have to do no matter where you are no
matter where you are you have to be
intentional with your money and so it's
always hard for me though because i am a
natural spender
love spending money i think it's awesome
people that are natural savers i don't
really get it
you're one of those i'm like oh my gosh
like just have some fun george is a
serious nerd yeah george and that's
coming from dave ramsey so oh it's just
a big just saying a big statement but
it's true i mean it really does give you
freedom so for those of you that feel
like this is going to be restrictive i
don't want this telling me what to do it
really does give you that permission you
feel good about spending because it was
in the budget you had a plan you paid
attention to your money that's exactly
exactly right and that's what i
experienced so just the encouragement
there for you all
either watching this or here tonight
that this is something that it has to be
part of your financial plan you have to
be intentional and tell your money where
to go every dollar it's my favorite
budgeting app i love it so much
literally last night i was laying in bed
and i got an email about a sale
shocking i know
unsubscribe i know i should have but i
didn't and i did it i clicked on every
dollar right there on my phone i was
like okay how much do we have budgeted
for the rest of this month i was like
okay
and i was able to buy some clothes and
it felt great because i was like i know
exactly the money i have to spend it
gives you a boundary it gives you it
gives you a guidance but it allows you
to live life to know that i can do these
things have fun with my money still but
i'm doing it in a wise way that's not
going to harm my future so the budget is
one thing that i'm like everyone you
have to have it you have to have it and
every dollar plus i love it's inside
ramsey plus um but every dollar it's
it's the thing that is safe the budget
is it follows really
an overarching i mean it's a tactical
thing to do yeah but philosophically it
follows a basic success principle that
no one
ever that you meet that wins big
does so
accidentally
it's a series of intentional acts
i mean we saw georgia alabama the other
night wow what a football game
man that's pretty good that was a
football game that was amazing i mean i
actually and i didn't think it was going
to be it looked like it was just going
to be 9-6 or something but um
but you know they didn't come up at the
end
to you know to kirby smart or to the
quarterback or the guy who won mvp and
they go you know how did you do this how
did you win the national championship
and he goes oh no i just got off the bus
no they had a game plan yes and they had
worked all season as a matter of fact
they'd worked their whole
life
to be able to do that skill level to
play at that level
to win the national championship that
particular night it was a whole series
over decades
for those young men
of intentional acts
to be at the top of the top of the top
you don't accidentally win
and so budgeting is just it's a it's a
manifestation of that success principle
of intentionality and what's interesting
to me though even with it again harping
only did no matter where you are no
matter where you are so even people on
baby step seven
you still have to be intentional with
exactly what you're doing you have to
have your goals you have to know what's
going on those of you starting on baby
step one you have to know what's going
on so that budget i love it it gives me
the control the freedom to kind of live
life and i'll tell you like winston and
i we've we have three little ones at
home
and it is like we are in the grind right
i mean it's just like school drop off
you're making lunches you're going to
work i mean bath time you're just doing
it all
and the one thing that is steady when it
comes to a subject that can be really
volatile
is that the budget is like our it's our
safety net where i'm like okay we can go
back to this we agree on it we see it we
know it so it is it's a it's a big
answer it answers one of life's most
important questions rachel order pizza
don't worry everyone that's happening
tomorrow night well you know as we talk
about building wealth it's fascinating
as we take calls on the ramsay show a
lot of people call in they say dave
george you know uh so i'm out of debt
except for my student loans and my car
payment and we're just sitting there
just running here like oh gosh how
and so i just want to make this very
clear
what debt is some people don't know it's
owing anything to anyone for any reason
it's as simple as that and until you get
control of that it's really hard to
build wealth while you have your car
payment and your student loan and your
credit card payment and you're trying to
invest up to the employer match and
you're wondering why you're not getting
rich why you're not building wealth and
so i want to talk about debt
because it's one of the best ways to
give yourself a raise and get that
margin in your life so that you can
invest and uh you know we talk about the
debt snowball as one of the best ways
and people love to argue this with with
dave on the show well dave
mathematically the avalanche method
there's no millionaires getting made
from the avalanche method where are they
i'd love to meet them the debt snowball
works every time you work it you list
your debts
from smallest to largest and ignore the
interest rate i know that blows in
people's minds but it's incredible what
happens when you focus on progress and
you attack the smallest one with a
vengeance and you're willing to sell
stuff and get a side job and cut some
expenses and subscriptions temporarily
so that you can get out of debt and once
you do the traction you have to be able
to see progress the human psyche
requires
progress
we get bored if we don't see progress we
won't stay with it if we don't see
progress we were gamified long before
there was nintendo or atari right yeah i
mean
we our hard wiring is that we need to
see something moving for our efforts or
we won't stay engaged and that's the
beauty that's why the debt snowball has
been so successful over all these
decades yeah and we had a debt-free
scream yesterday on the air aaron from
missouri is she in here
i did one too that's right that's true
that is true
okay
george well speaking of getting out of
debt uh we got out of debt uh we had
gotten out of debt a long time ago
consumer debt and yesterday me and my
wife who also works at ramsey solutions
we really drank the kool-aid dave uh we
we did our debt-free screen because we
paid off our house
thank you and how old are you uh so
i'm 32 years old my wife is 31 we paid
off 165 000 in 26 months we just went
intense so good
so that's the and it was amazing seeing
other team members go i want to go home
and talk to my spouse how do we get rid
of this house faster how do we build
welfare george can do it i mean that's
exactly what it is
if that's what it takes i'm happy about
it but it is true dave you know i
started here nine years ago as an intern
and a temp and i i had 40 percent
a lowly intern on the totem pole there
and i came in with 40 000 in debt i had
student loans and credit cards and i
just thought this is normal i was trying
to get the rewards i was oh they got
five percent cash back on gas this month
this is how i'm going to get wealthy
it didn't work out and so i got on board
with our plan i went through financial
peace university
and i paid off that forty thousand
dollars in two years and i never looked
back and it's been absolutely incredible
but this other debt freedom whitney
would marry you and then my wife said
yeah i'll marry you no no that's not
what happened
but she's always been a lot smarter we
met she was already debt-free we started
off our marriage debt-free we were
already on the same page and it was
incredible what happens when you get on
the same page with your spouse and you
guys have your eye on a prize yeah yeah
it's incredible but we had a difference
you guys will be a babysitter
millionaire soon with the paid off house
and your 401k in our early 30s 30s in
your early 30s yeah so we're really
excited about that but um aaron from
missouri came by did her debt-free
scream 40 000 paid off in 24 months and
it was fascinating what she was saying
as she was on this journey
she got connected with financial peace
university she was in ramsey plus and
she said i hired a financial coach
because i wanted someone who could speak
specifically to my situation and help me
make better decisions and that's one of
those things you kind of forget that oh
i can bring someone along this journey
who can walk with me who can help me and
in ramsay plus we have live group q a
coaching for free multiple times a week
you can connect one-on-one with a coach
in your area and that's one of the
biggest game changers if you feel like
you need that push more traction get
plugged into that stuff something she's
single mom had her 15 year old daughter
standing there with her to do the
debt-free scream it was sweet yeah it
was inspiring very sweet
so i feel like these are some of the
foundational kind of building blocks as
you move to build wealth but today
and you touched on some of them earlier
but i'm like there's just so many terms
and things happening right now that are
in the news social media friends are
talking about you talk about over the
holidays with family i mean it's just
it's constant it's everywhere and it's
like one of those big things is
inflation
yeah and so it's a it's a term that
we're hearing constantly obviously it's
an issue you you joked earlier that that
george and i us young ones we didn't
know jimmy carter we were not alive in
the 70s and the early 80s
uh well i mean i was i was 22 years old
in 1982. so we'll talk okay you can go
back there for sure and inflation
inflation was
okay basic like
econ 101. well but the bottom line is
that i experienced that real inflation
and inflation in the 70s was running
double digits it was running 10 12
which for the record we're at like seven
percent right now well that was the
latest report that came out three days
ago yeah and so
and so
that inflation was caused by inflation
is simply increasing prices it's simply
what it's inflation like you're blowing
up a balloon it's inflated that's all it
means increasing prices increasing
prices so then you've got to get under
it and say what is the cause of the
inflation the inflation in those days
was caused by monetary policy the fed
shrinking and growing this money supply
and they were monkeying with the economy
doing that and they couldn't get it
straight and it ended up you know
bringing ronald reagan in following
jimmy carter it was one of the things
that changed the regime so to speak in
the politics
today's inflation that we're
experiencing is a different
reason for the inflation
we had a an earthquake at sea
when you have an earthquake at sea it
stirs up the sea
and following that a few hours or even
days later a tsunami rises up
and hits
this inflation is the tsunami
as a result of the pandemic quarantine
shutting down
the economy and shutting down the
production of goods and services created
a shortage of almost every kind of good
or service world wide
there's a shortage of lumber for houses
there was a shortage of glass you can
name it there's a shortage of anything
you want to name and when there's a
shortage of something and there's six
people wanting to buy it and there used
to be six things that price stayed
pretty stable but when now we have six
people wanting to buy it oh better than
that they came out of their cave
after the nuclear winter of the
quarantine really hungry to buy
something because they hadn't been able
to buy anything for a while and so the
consumer has gone bananas on their
purchasing and so we used to have six
people trying to buy six things now
we've got a shortage we've got one thing
and we've got 12 people trying to buy it
well guess what that does they fight
over it and drive the price up
it's a supply demand curve from the
seventh grade economics class okay and
so this drive the
disruption of the production and the
supply chain bringing the stuff in so
there's stuff's not there and when
there's a shortage
100 of the time
too many people chasing two food goods
and services you're going to see an
increase in price and so that that's the
tsunami that is here and add to that the
biden administration has got a war going
against gasoline and against the oil
industry and so basically the cost of
gas at the pump due to their policies
has doubled
that's not a shortage that's a created
shortage with their policies so you've
got a political thing going and you've
got the quarantine thing going they're
driving these two sets of prices up and
this is where this inflation is coming
from that's the bad news the good news
is after the tsunami hits it goes back
out to sea
it's not a steady inflation so you're
not going to have this type of inflation
this cause of inflation last 10 years it
mathematically can't last 10 years
because the factories catch up on
production and now again you've and the
people slow down on their purchases
because the prices have gone up and so
now you've got six people chasing six
goods again and the prices stabilize
they may come back down but they at
least won't go straight through the roof
they may even out where they are you may
not see a reduction in prices but you
know five years from today this cause of
inflation will be gone now you could
bring back the other causes but it's not
we've never seen it
positive
it might be 36 months it might be 24
months yeah but well but you know we're
already seeing for instance lumber
coming down
lumber prices are coming down the reason
is factories have caught up the purchase
prices have gone high enough on new
housing as a result that it's slowing
down that portion of the economy a
little bit and your goods your number of
people chasing the number of goods and
slowing down you're going to see it even
out which is great but i think the
reality day to day i mean to scare
people well it scares people and today i
went literally to the gas station before
i got here filled up my car it was on
empty and i was like oh my god
it's expensive i mean it's just a lot
it's a lot more so the margin twice as
much as it was yeah so the margin in
your budget the margin that we're
feeling of what we used to have we're
just you're just spending more my
grocery budget is insane like what we
spent what i spent at costco on sunday
it was stupid and i was like we didn't
buy that much but like it's it's crazy
the prices right now and so i think for
a lot of people let's be clear when
costco's fault they're just they're
passing on the prices they got it yeah
oh yeah they're not blaming costs
i'm just saying like when you're buying
groceries if i would piss somebody off
and do it on purpose okay that's right
that's right that's all right
don't mess with kirkland's signature
okay rachel i love costco okay
no but the but i think that's why it's
even that more important you guys to be
intentional with your money because that
margin is a real thing
in our budgets and in our day-to-day
life that we're feeling so that rub so
that does cause fear
you got a whole generation that's never
felt inflation and the shock of this 100
if you turn on the news it's like pure
fear porn yeah i mean fear you're going
to die you're going to die everything's
going up in price and you're going to
die and you're going up in pricing and
you're going to die and just if you just
watch it all day long you're like i'm
going to die you know it's like and so
you get this your whole all your
physiology like dr dawn talks about gets
activated and then you're set up for
these get rich quick but you would be
for a lot of people though that are you
know paycheck paycheck and you feel like
you have my experience right you fill up
with the tank you go to cost and you're
thinking oh this is this is scary i've
got to change my investments because i'm
not going to keep up
and i'm about to get straight right so
the fear
so the fear aspect it is very real it is
very very rare but the antidote is the
margin you can't let that control you
that's right yeah and so one of the
margins margin is a fancy word for
saying we got it we got to spend less we
might need to make more and that's where
this budget really comes into play are
you even paying attention where can we
trim can we cut some subscriptions can
we trim the fat off this thing are we
willing to take a side job for a
temporary amount of time to clean up a
mess and not have this weight of oh my
gosh gas is a dollar more and my life is
ruined i want you to have the margin to
where you go you kind of yawn and go oh
inflation's up another percent oh well
we'll adjust the budget move on yeah
that's what financial peace is all about
that's right that's the goal for sure
and that's why this plan works because
it allows you to have that peace in the
middle of kind of that chaos that you
feel so another
kind of term or idea that has been
floated around i feel like not as much
in the past like month or two but it's
been there is student loan forgiveness
and it's uh interesting as i kind of dig
into this and talk to people in this
because you know they paused
um you know the student payments during
during all the pandemic stuff and and
what it caused though for a lot of
people i think was to be a little bit
more passive
when it comes specifically to student
loans but i think it i think it seeped
into other areas of life and their money
of sitting back thinking okay someone
really could just take care of this i'm
going to kind of sit back
and allow others calvary is coming yeah
and i think that it was something that a
lot of people did believe but as you as
you dive in you know the average person
that now has i think it's 37 close to 37
000 in student loan debt so
there is something
so real about it but there's also
something real about that passive
mentality
that you have to break of believing that
other people are going to help you build
this wealth listen the problem becomes
whatever the program is
or whatever the promise is
that is made from washington dc that's
going to make you wealthy
if they convince you of that therefore
you stop making yourself wealthy
you're screwed
that's the problem
that's what that passivity is because
people have become convinced that
they're going to forgive the student
loans they may or may not but to date
0.6
about a half of 1
of the student loans ever made have ever
been forgiven
to date
and there are three programs currently
for student loan forgiveness
death
disability
and the private student loan program
where the public student loan
forgiveness program where you work 10
years in a non-profit setting or an
underserved setting and 280 000 people
have applied for that only 6 000 people
have been granted that
so what we find is is that people who
depend on washington to have a good life
their life sucks
democrat or republican it doesn't matter
regardless of what yes who's there you
know trump didn't send me any money
and neither did biden
and neither did clinton and do i need to
keep going
all the way to carter david
went back there right
if you need some cash i got you today
lincoln didn't send me any money
oh
you're not that old dave
come on now but the thing with student
unforgiveness and we take calls about
this and and we have to go here's why
you shouldn't bank on this 10 years from
now is because we want you to be in
control
and when you put your future in someone
else's hands to hope that it happens you
are not in control by definition and the
public sector often is going to pay less
and so you're saying i'm going to stick
inside of a job that pays less that i
may not even enjoy
just so hopefully one day my student
loans are forgiven no in 18 to 24 months
on average that's how long it takes for
people to pay off their consumer debt
you can pay off your student loans and
move on with your life for the next
eight years and build wealth and i think
it's important too i think though i
think they'll send you a signal if
they're gonna forgive them
if they're gonna forgive them it means
they really have come to the conclusion
that the student loan is a bad idea i
thought it was good that day and so if
they come to the conclusion that it's so
bad that it needs to be forgiven then
they will stop making the loans
when they stop making them
they might be getting ready to forgive
them but until then this whole
discussion is intellectually dishonest
boom and it's giving a false hope as
well a false narrative around it and
again just a reminder of
you said it well george but that all of
this thing we're talking about tonight
right the idea of building wealth it has
to come from you it's going to come from
you and so
being passive towards it is not going to
help you so that that proactiveness is
so so key
okay another term you ready uh-oh
cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency these people are
passionate george they're very important
thing on the fine print on crypto and it
was really well done thank you but i
thought i was going to find you hanging
from a tree somewhere after i was
nervous oh my gosh they were so angry at
you i saw the christmas
yeah they were coming after you and i
thought i'm next and i don't have enough
money to keep them away but here's the
deal
here's the deal here's what i found out
i was wondering why it's not crypto
itself that i was uh didn't like it was
the people that were really into it and
here's my my conclusion cryptocurrency
is mary kay for young men
that's it
that's it
i'm sorry
i'm smart drop
okay that's funny i don't care who you
are sorry
they're obsessed rachel they're obsessed
i know i know i know i i know okay expl
you do you did this on the fine print so
do a high level explanation of what
cryptocurrency is and let's talk about
it because you ha you guys both have
more of a i don't talk about it this
time but you all have more of a somewhat
balanced view than people give you
credit for i think a lot of people have
assumed oh you're not allowed to talk
about it unless you're endorsing it by
these people because they go bananas
okay i'm just setting you up for what
we're going to talk about thank you
rachel so george will you give us the
donation and then i do want you to hear
i want to hear the the approach about it
because i think it is a little different
than people okay maybe just assume
stereotypically you're the expert one of
the most dangerous things you can do is
try to define cryptocurrency in 30
seconds so this is a very risky move you
got it for the sake of everyone out
there i'm gonna try okay
cryptocurrency virtual currency that can
be traded instantly worldwide 24 7 with
little to no fees and it's not
controlled by any one entity or
government or company or person so
people love the future by the way i like
that part a lot yes so dave likes that
part but here's the thing when it's 24 7
it means you can watch it go up and down
which that's pretty much all it does 24
7. at 4 00 am you can watch this thing
go up and down and the craziest part is
its value is based on speculation and
hype
most of the coins out there are just
speculation and hype elon musk says it's
going to go up so i guess we should all
buy it before it goes up
that's it well listen
let's just be clear there's a again
basic economic
concept here
if you take an item i don't care what
that is that's called a commodity
and just like earlier when we said six
people chasing one item drives the price
up
on that commodity
and that is different than an investment
an investment generates
revenue generates money generates profit
and so if you buy a rental house you get
rent
real money and so you can say based on
the money that it is creating not its
increase in value but the money that it
is creating i can give it a value
that's an investment a stock
the company is making a profit
and so based on the money i put in and
then the money that company is creating
back to me the owner the stockholder
then there's something happening there
but if it's orange juice if you remember
trading places with eddie murphy right
and orange juice futures you're just
fighting over a fixed amount of orange
juice and a number of people coming at
it small number of people comes at it
price goes down large number of people
goes at it price goes up and that's how
crypto goes up or that's how gold goes
up
that's you know in value or down in
value gold has no value except the
number of people chasing it based on
fear or greed crypto has no inherent
value it's a digit for god's sakes it
has no in but paper has no inferent
value but we put a president's face on
it and we declare it to be valuable so
we're all agreeing to change it and it's
it's acceptable then we can change it
but if a large number of people chase a
few dollars the value of the dollar goes
up a currency goes up but a currency is
a type of commodity as well so this is
how commodities work this is why when
you play commodities on the commodities
market it's a very high risk play
because you're anticipating the demand
and that's all you can anticipate and
crypto is exactly the same way i think
crypto will be around i think it's going
to be with us i think it's kind of cool
i like the vibe on it i can't stand the
cult like following and the idiocy
that's around some of that but i like
the fact that it's outside government
control that's kind of cool i'm kind of
libertarian that way that's neat i like
government screen with anything if i
could help it and so i like that part
but if i and i think it's going to
survive i think it's going to be okay
but until it is proven over a decade or
two to create wealth for the typical guy
out there
i wouldn't put much money in it no more
than you would put at the craps table
yes which speaking of the crap that's
okay i think it's so dave doesn't like
to lose money rachel is okay going to
vegas at the coin slots there i have an
envelope i had another crap symbol i did
i had an envelope and once it was gone i
have failed as a father oh boy i'm sorry
wow
save the secrets for later but here's
the deal like it's like going to vegas a
little bit it's like walking up to the
roulette table yes and going all right
let's put it let's put it on red see
what happens and then you win you go hey
hey guys come over here i made some
money do exactly what i did and uh maybe
you'll make money too and they don't and
so don't tell me you're investing in
crypto it's fine if you say i'm playing
with crypto that's fine but do it when
you're out of debt you have a fully
funded emergency fund you're already
investing 15
into real things like your 401k your
roth ira that's great and then if you've
got some entertainment money because
that's what it is i'm totally fine with
you amen spending on crypto
that's the balance approach here right
in that case i would invest in crypto
let me know i would buy crypto
corrections yeah that was a good
correction
so changing with crypto we have to talk
about nfts you all heard about nfts
right
non-fungible tokens it really is a fun
word whoever came up with that they were
happy
and so this this is basically digital
ownership so i can take a picture of
dave ramsey that i found online and i
can make it an nft i can mint it and i
can sell that photo to somebody
dave ramsey fan
and you can say i am the official owner
of this specific version of this image
and so here's a great way to a great
analogy for you y'all ever seen those
websites that let you buy a star in the
galaxy
that is an nft that's all it is so
you're buying a star in the galaxy you
can point up and go oh that's it's up
there i know it is
it's basically um it's a treasure map
that points to the treasure you don't
own the treasure the creator owns a
treasure in this case god uh but in the
nfc case it's usually an artist right so
people are going oh i'm going to buy
this nft hoping that another sucker is
going to pay a lot more than i did for
it that's all nfts are 23 year old
called me on the air today with john
dolone on the air with me and he makes
90 000 a year at 23 years old he lost 15
000 in one month buying nfts
23 years old
this is the kind of stuff that's driving
me nuts yeah dave what's even crazier is
i heard someone just this is a big nft
fan he was describing it and he said you
know you have a sense of ownership and i
immediately went oh my gosh that's how
they pitch time shares that's who you
know it's a terrible terrible investment
by the way do you know who the uh
timeshares are timeshare guys are
they're the grandsons of the guys that
did the swampland oh
is that a joke or is that for real
that's a joke okay
got some swamp land i was like
uh it's a real estate joke dave loves a
good real estate job i'm sorry
i was a little slow
listen if you if you wanna that's fine
that's right
we live in a culture that has so much
anxiety already and so i like to take
that part out and go i'm not going to
mess with all of these things and here's
what i like to say if you follow the
trends you will fall for the traps and a
lot of these trends they're trying to
squeeze please
tremendously fall for the trap george
thank you that's good but that's really
that was the heart of the fine print is
trying to uncover what's going on in the
world right now and point back to the
proven principles you're not seeing the
fine print podcast we did a whole season
of this kind of stuff with georgia the
host you need to check it out it's
really great thank you so i think the
the spirit of all this right whether you
know it's crypto you know all of this
there's a level of sure i think of greed
of like okay i can just get rich quick
it doesn't take a lot um but i know even
talking to some of my friends even
though that there's a
there is this sense of gosh we're
working hard right it's not like they're
not lazy they're not unwise
but it's like okay we're working hard
we're doing every month we're doing our
budget you know maybe they're on baby
steps four five and six but they're you
know fun to retirement kids college
they're putting next to the house you're
trying to stay for a vacation they're
replacing a car seat i mean they're
they're doing all this stuff
and it can be tiring right you do this
over a long period of time and like yeah
sometimes you get the good wins and you
feel energized but sometimes it's just
life and life is tiring and you work
hard you come home
you know you do dinner you get to be i
mean it's just you're in it and so i
think for for some people
it feels in the easy button i think
would be a thing it's an easy but it's
it's relief it's like oh could i just
put my money in something and i could
get a really fast return and i don't
have to do
all this hard work
over decades and decades it sounds like
a relief more than like greed or
laziness there's a level for people
where it's like that's what you're
searching for but that sets your feet up
in the news so that's the problem so
like when you sit down with a good smart
investor pro
and they unpack and they actually teach
you
how the mutual fund works and so you're
able to select the right mutual fund you
know what you're doing then by working
with someone with the heart of a teacher
that's different than i'm buying
something that i don't even know what it
is or how it works because it's trendy
and i'm looking for easy so it's a whole
different thing and by the way those of
you that are on baby step four five and
six
be putting 15 percent in
don't be it's not a theory it's not 22
percent it's not 12
and it's not 6 percent and i'll catch up
with it later some people hit that baby
step three and when they get to baby
step four they let their foot off the
gas
baby that's when it's game on and so you
sit down and i understand you get tired
i've been working a long time like
sometimes i get tired too but but here's
the thing if i'm gonna be tired i at
least want to be winning
yes amen oh amen amen
and i think that that's
the encouraging message here is that
that relief
yes it can come other places right you
go and you invest and you're wise with
where you're putting your money so you
get that return that relief can get
there but also to remember too the
journey throughout this wealth building
process you don't want to skip over
because there is an element of your
character that's formed there's an
element of delayed gratification that
seeps into other areas of your life
there's richness that through the hard
work and through the diligence of it
there's something in there that is so
good and we are so used to instance we
want things fast because it feels good
that's what we want
and i think that's a really really
dangerous play so there's beauty in the
journey so i just want to encourage you
guys if it was easy it wouldn't force
you to work together in your marriage
and cause your marriage to draw together
absolutely yeah
but the fact that we're fighting a
battle causes us to draw together as a
husband and wife and and actually
communicate and actually lean in and go
we're gonna do come on we can do it come
on and you lift each other up and you're
carrying each other along like you're in
this battle and
and so but if one of you just reaches
over there on the internet at 2am and
hits the easy button i mean none of that
happens
and besides that it doesn't work
i love the microwave crockpot analogy
how many all burnt popcorn in the
microwave because it went two seconds
over
right that's culture they're gonna get
burnt but the crock pot right grandma's
crock pot i said it and forget it like
ron papil remember the old rotisserie
chicken and it's so great you can't mess
up the crock pot that is why i love the
crock pot you just leave it alone
and it works and yes it will take four
hours instead of 30 seconds but you're
gonna actually keep your wealth and it
reminds me that proverbs 13 11 verse
wealth gained hastily will dwindle but
whoever gathers little by little will
increase it right and i love that spirit
that's the underlying truth of the whole
night right there
so our 14-day free trial on ramsey plus
includes financial peace university
includes the every dollar app includes
the coaching that george was talking
about the 1000 books with the first 1000
sign up are already gone they're gone
uh so the guys told me right before i
walked out they said let's go ahead and
do something else the next five thousand
of you we've got about 150 000 watching
out there the next 5 000 of you that go
ahead and do a free trial at ramsey plus
and give this a try we're going to give
you the audio book for the baby steps
millionaire free so go ahead if you
haven't gone to ramsey solutions.com
wealth and signed up go ahead and do
that and give it a try it's free it's a
free trial and you're going to get the
audio book to keep regardless of what
happens so do the free trial get in
there and look at this the the what is
the best
fastest
way the highest probability that's what
i'm always looking for
and of everything i've ever done in my
life this is the one that works the best
uh the thing that gets there the best
and i think the good news is people can
do it
absolutely and well and what i think is
so
really cool where we're sitting today at
this time i'm like you know over 30
years of doing it
i'm meeting people in their 20s who are
like yeah i mean my parents took
financial university and now i went to
college that free and they have this
whole story
this spring board that they get to start
off on because their parents chose
something different and that's my story
i mean i'm sitting here today because of
him
and mom and and the choices that they
made
it did the idea that it changes your
family tree it really does like it
really does there's an impact that is so
much greater than those of you that are
here that it goes so beyond you and
there's something beautiful about it
right and it's not just handing them
money it's handing them a set of
principles to live by that is part of
their story forever and ever and so
all of you
it is so possible number one absolutely
when we get these stories i feel like
that's the privilege of our jobs we get
to hear success stories we hear the
problems for sure but we get to hear the
success stories of people
all different walks of life all income
levels all debt levels everything walk
this plan
and truly do they become every day they
become they become millionaires and it's
it's a beautiful beautiful thing and it
is possible for everyone but remember
it's bigger than you
it's bigger than you other people's
lives are going to be touched by the
choices that you make today with your
money well i'm sitting here with
a guy who's getting ready to be a
millionaire in his 30s
that has been on our team met his wife
on our team all of that i'm sitting here
with another generation following these
principles and i'm sitting here with all
of you guys and
it's just i gotta tell you man
it is so
fun
it's so rewarding and so so filling
to
meet you folks that have done these
things and see the stuff you've done
you're incredible
i mean so many of you
are the things you've pulled off and
that your steadiness and your maturity
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
you guys i mean
tens of thousands of people out there
that i've had the honor of meeting and
hearing your overcomers story i'm so
proud of you
and all we want for you at ramsey is
really simple we make plenty of money
we're doing all right but what we want
for you is we want to see you move the
needle we want to see you
you know dial this in a little tighter
or do it for the first time and i just
don't want to see you fall for stuff
that doesn't work or that's unproven i
don't want to see you go through pain i
hate talking to that little 23 year old
today and lost 15 000
and deloney and i told him we said it's
really good that you lost it because
you'll never do it again
that's true never do it again yeah and
he that really won the answer he wanted
but it's the one he needed to hear you
know when it comes to this stuff i
always think of this this quote you know
people underestimate people overestimate
what they can accomplish in a year and
they underestimate what they can
accomplish in a decade and especially
with with our story me and my wife it's
amazing that people don't have a vision
for what they want five years from now
ten years from now they're thinking
about this weekend next week they're
living paycheck to paycheck they want to
get rich quick there's all these trends
and if you can just keep your eye on the
prize year after year consistently with
discipline and the character that
creates goodness gracious we need more
character than ever in the world today
we got a character shortage in this
country and then you can just stick to
we got some characters
a lot of characters but we have a
character sure yes and so that's my
encouragement to you guys i'm not
special i'm not rich i'm just a guy who
went all in not ish on this plan and i'm
telling you it works you do have good
hair thank you that helps
that's the one thing i have over dave
[Laughter]
guys we're honored to be with you all
tonight we love you we're so glad you're
here thank you for spending your evening
with us please go win turn this country
around let's have the good people take
it back and all this craziness is out
there and toxicity and division and hate
it needs to be pushed down by the good
people and we need to go win and cause
this to happen thanks for being with us
y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you